If you're learning Power BI,
you probably work in Excel quite a lot already,
or maybe you have some familiarity with SQL.
This training assumes no experience with Power BI or SQL,
but it anticipates that you are comfortable with basic Excel functions,
such as writing common formulas in Excel to perform
calculations such as SUM or Average, and creating tables.
Familiarity with using pivot tables to analyze
data is also very helpful but not essential.
To be clear, it's not necessary for you to know SQL to succeed in this course.
But because SQL, M code,
and DAX are often just similar enough to trip you up,
I'll include some pointers throughout this course for those of you
who do have a SQL background to help you avoid getting stuck.
A good example that I run into whenever I'm not paying
attention is using double quotes instead of single ones in DAX formulas.
Provided you have the prerequisites I just mentioned,
you probably already know some data modeling before we even start.
A flat table, like the ones you've worked with in Excel is of simple data model.
So you already have some experience creating simple data models.
If you're familiar with common Excel functions,
you actually already know some DAX.
Common examples of measures that are identical in Excel and DAX include: SUM, IF,
MIN, MAX, AVERAGE, ABSOLUTE,
Round, and Today, although there are many others.